bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur leur
tv fil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du
journal d'informations locales ont ce 10
février il sera notamment à question de
l'agglomération de 50 ans elle doit se
doter d'un contrat de développement
territorial d'ici la fin de l'année un
document qui va définir les grands
aménagements notamment en matière de
transport et de développement économique
pour les dix prochaines années dans
chaque canton le front national sera
bien présent dans les yvelines les noms
viennent d'être dévoilées à six semaines
du premier tour des élections
et puis dans les yvelines un nouveau
directeur académique vient d'être nommé
serge clément est l'invité du journal
pour évoquer son parcours et les actions
qu'ils souhaitent mettre en place le 8
mars prochain il sera obligatoire pour
tous les foyers de s'équiper d'un
détecteur de fumée ce qui permettrait
d'éviter 50 % des morts par asphyxie
lors d'un incendie une campagne
explicative a été lancé par le préfet ce
matin campagne nationale qui prend une
dimension particulière dans les yvelines
le département est en effet à l'origine
de la loi pierre morange député de la 6e
circonscription des yvelines a déposé le
texte à l'assemblée l'homme politique
s'est lancé dans ce combat suite au
décès d'une jeune fille de 16 ans dans
un incendie à charnay c'était en 2002 on
les écoute ma de moustiques ou en fait
habiter à saint-nom-la-bretèche mais sa
fille était avait passé une soirée avec
des amis en effet acharné et el mar
l'assesseur raconter cette histoire
terrible larmes aux yeux avec une
dignité une émotion
qui prenait à la gorge véritablement et
pour le médecin
le maire d'un village le père de famille
le parlementaire ayant quelques lueurs
en matière de protection sanitaire et
sociale et bien évidemment je lui ai
proposé que nous nous battions ensemble
afin que de cette souffrance eh bien
nous puissions et bien la mettre au
service de tous chaque année les
incendies tue entre une et six personnes
dont le département élections cantonales
départemental le front national qui
selon ce aussi dans la bataille la
formation de marine le pen sera présente
dans les 21 cantons que compte le
département des yvelines les listes
composées d'un binôme hommes femmes
viennent d'être déposées en préfecture
catherine viau l'atome le front national
est le premier parti de france sur dans
l'ensemble de la france
maintenant ce que nous voudrions c'est
transformer l'essai et faire en sorte
que le front national soit aussi le
premier parti des effluents et pour ce
faire le parti de marine le pen a
mobilisé pour cette départementale ses
candidats élus les plus emblématiques
tels que le maire de mantes la ville
cyril notre le seul maire effet l'île de
france qui tentera de faire barrage à
pierre bédier
mais également des conseillers
municipaux il était logique que nous
présentions notamment les personnes
élues sur le sur les élections
départementales
en tant qu'ancien militaire et ancien
gendarme je suis très sensibilisés par
la sécurité je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est véritablement un des points
faibles du gouvernement et les thèmes
seront nationale parce que forcément je
crois que que les français sont en
attente de quelque chose de fort qui
n'arrive pas immigration chômage
insécurité
enfin tous les échecs de l'ump du ps
depuis 40 ans d'autres sont plus haut
niveau politique comme eric jégo est
elle de oliviera tout juste 19 ans ces
valeurs qui nous ont été transmis à la
fac qui m'a donné l'envi de m'engager au
front national
liberté égalité fraternité c'est une
notion un petit des notions qui sont
abstraites
de mon point de vue on peut pas les
retrouver dans l'actualité ou même dans
notre vie quotidienne
je suis un peut apporter ma pierre à
tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui puisque
pour moi en fait le peuple français est
un peu lâché la jeunesse des candidats
c'est sur ce point que veut aussi miser
le front national pour ces élections
à l'image de perrine jauniaux adhérentes
du front national à 16 ans et candidate
à 18 ans seulement
je montre exemple aux jeunes qu'aux
espaces présenté au front national
l'immigration le
luro l'insécurité il chômage
je pense très sincèrement que le front
national est la seule alternative
possible non seulement au niveau
national mais aussi au niveau local sur
tous les problèmes déjà de travail
problèmes de précarité dans le travail
problème de chômage problèmes de
logement la sécurité un thème récurrent
pour les candidats moi je suis
commerçante
j'ai 46 ans et je vois énormément de
misère autour de moi les clients qui se
plaignent les 2 to de la sécurité
beaucoup de leurs aussi beaucoup
commença à étouffer je m'engage un petit
peu plus parce que je voudrais quand
même peu que les choses bougent un peu
parce que bon je me reconnais plus
tellement dans ces 62 ans et je
reconnais plus du tout la france en 2011
lors des dernières cantonales le front
national avait présenté des candidats
dans chacun des cantons renouvelables
on reste dans la politique et henri
pailleux qui quitte la mairie de
coignières ce sera soit en mars ou en
avril la date n'a pas encore été
clairement fixée une des missions assez
surprenant car non après les municipales
nous avons rencontré henri pailleux
alors qu'il dédicaçait son ouvrage la
force de la conviction c'est à la maison
du voisinage donc dans sa commune
l'occasion aussi de demander aux
habitants de coignières comment il
réagit c'est la force de la conviction
c'est le nom du livre caen et bayeux
vient de publier le maire de coignières
est un homme de caractère il l'a prouvé
en annonçant son départ surprise de la
mairie dans son ouvrage le maire de
coignières raconte toute sa vie depuis
l'âge de deux ans car dit il il a une
mémoire d'éléphant man une carrière
riche et diverse
j'ai travaillé dans le nu théâtre était
enseignant chercheur à l'université
enseigner les mathématiques et la
physique
je suis un montagnard de haut vol parce
que j'ai fait avec de l'intérêt et
gaston rebuffat je vais tous les sommets
des alpes à plusieurs reprises
d'ailleurs
l'armée pour moi étaient des voisins ça
fait du mans fabuleuse où j'ai passé 16
mois merveilleux
je me suis engagé en 58 cents politique
dès le retour du général de gaulle
d'ailleurs je suis gaulliste je suis est
membre d'un parti au début des années 80
on répète je crée même un club de
gastronomie en 1986 il devient maire de
coignières je n'ai jamais cherché à une
merde quoi dr je n'ai jamais cherché à
être conseiller général des yvelines
c'est venu comme ça naturellement on va
dire par des trains qui l'ont passé jour
- dans lesquels je suis monté son départ
de la mairie cela devait se faire à mi
mandat
finalement ce sera plus tôt que prévu
l'intercommunalité avec l'intégration de
coignières à saint quentin en yvelines
et le projet dadoun rayé du schéma
directeur de la région ile-de-france ont
fini par le convaincre de quitter son
poste dans le monde tel qu'il évolue et
la france telle qu'elle évolue je suis
désolé de le dire il ya plus d'éthique
il ya plus de morale il n'y a que
l'intérêt particulier par le passé
l'intérêt général et ça pour moi c'est
absolument insupportable
je suis en rupture totale avec le dire
est ce plus bas est renseigné par mes
parents par les jésuites parce que j'ai
passé 10 ans chez eux ses débuts mais
ils m'ont adressé quand il fallait et
donc je suis arrivé à prendre et puis je
suis un peu déçu parce que moi en tant
que maire mais on l'aimé bien mais bon
tout a une fin
il a fait beaucoup de choses pour la
commune de poignard franchement oui
en tant que maire heureux pour moi tout
est positif
comme tout le monde c'est estomaqué ici
repos hier on garde les élus assez
longtemps et puis c'était moi même fils
d'un maire henri duriez donc qui n'est
pas resté si longtemps mais j'ai connu
monsieur vient aussi donc ça me paraît
presque logique de rester longtemps
quand on est habitués qu'on sait mener
la commune ils aiment avoir des idées
il ne prend pas toujours celles des
autres et il les prend son prendre
quelques années plus tard
que c'est dommage qu il aurait pu céder
son mandat au mi mandat de l'ancienne
mandature
c'était plus simple plutôt que de
vouloir continuer d'arrêter le quelques
mois après sports ont été moi je pense
qu'il a il donne la mairie pendant six
ans à la gauche henri payet n'a pas
encore choisi la date de son départ ce
sera soit le 5 mars jour de ses 75 ans
soit le 10 avril après le vote du budget
pour l'instant il ne veut pas non plus
dévoilé le nom de son successeur
une réunion publique pour présenter le
contrat de développement territorial
paris saclay et est organisée ce lundi
soir dans les yvelines le dossier
concerne versailles grand parc vélizy
villacoublay et 55 en yvelines l'enquète
publique est ouverte en mairie jusqu'au
27 février à tous les détails avec
michael almy d'euros et patrick jacques
de dixmude à définir les grands contours
de la zone paris saclay sur les 15
prochaines années c'est l'objectif du
contrat de développement territorial
présenté ce lundi soir le dossier vise à
établir une ligne directrice sur
l'urbanisme l'économie les moyens de
transport entre les communautés
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
vélizy saint quentin en yvelines mais
également avec la commune de bièvres un
bassin de vie qui comprend 1 18 communes
il ya beaucoup de projets en réalité il
ya des projets de nouveaux comme
le quartier louise michel a attrapé le
quartier de satory a rassemblé un peu
l'ensemble des projets dans une
dans une lettre dans une perspective
cohérente et puis un certain nombre de
projets d'infrastructure qui vont
améliorer la la circulation est à terme
la l'arrivée du métro de la ligne 10 8
dans la salle une centaine de curieux
s'est déplacé pour cette enquête
publique
objectif pour les habitants comprend d
apporter un oeil critique sur ce projet
c'est quand même assez complète donc on
vient le chercher à la source ces
informations aujourd'hui le but c'est
que tout le grand public
à vienne aussi le si vous voulez bien
sûr les présidents des associations qui
ce qui représente beaucoup d'adhérents
et c'est un mec que tous les citoyens
qui s'intéressent un petit peu la vie
locale à la vie de leur département
aussi fins de vienne s'exprimer écouter
écouter la présentation parce qu'un cdt
c'est pas facile à comprendre
le contrat de développement territorial
de paris saclay versailles grand parc
saint quentin en yvelines et vélizy
villacoublay téléchargeable sur le site
internet de la préfecture
les habitants de l'agglomération peuvent
venir consulter le dossier d' enquête
publique dans les mairies jusqu'au 27
février
ils sont également invités à déposer
leur avis je reçois pour ce journal à
présent serge clément bonsoir bon j'ai
de nouveau directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale dans
les yvelines nommé à la fin du mois de
décembre on va juste repréciser dans les
grandes lignes de votre rollin
globalement c'est de participer à la
définition des politiques éducatives
pédagogiques du primaire et du
secondaire également on va parler de
votre parcours mieux vous connaître et
puis parler de l'actualité et
l'actualité est local c'est le
rassemblement demain des parents
d'élèves de trappes notamment pour
protester contre les manques le manque
de professeurs remplaçants
vous avez la réponse pour eux dès ce
soir on a déjà une réponse puisque je
suis sollicité depuis maintenant
quelques jours par les parents d'élèves
des écoles primaires de trappes
on a
nous sommes fortement mobilisés de
manière à répondre à alors juste demande
bien entendu puisque chacun veut que ses
enfants soient non seulement accueilli
mais que les enseignements soient
données alors on a une tension
extrêmement forte qui nous faut assumer
on sait très bien que les période
actuelle sont toujours extrêmement
tendue que ce soit du mois de décembre
jusqu'au mois d'avril
voilà est là actuellement on a
effectivement une difficulté objective
nous avons re mobiliser des enseignants
pour le premier degré de manière à
assurer les remplacements qui sont dues
quitte à prendre il faut bien le dire
avec regret un sur notre capacité de
remplacement des professeurs qui partent
en formation
donc ce travail là nous obligent au delà
de cette situation à repenser l'ensemble
de du dispositif sur le département de
manière à voir où se condense j'allais
dire davantage les les absences
d'enseignants et de façon à mieux
réorganiser mieux rééquilibrer notre
potentiel de remplacement c'est un
travail qui se fera d'ailleurs en pleine
concertation avec leurs représentants
des personnels et de façon beaucoup plus
fine pour la rentrée prochaine
ce manque de professeurs remplaçants ses
propres attrape ou à l'ensemble du
département alors on est dans le train
d'identifier aujourd'hui les
circonscriptions puisque vous savez que
pour le premier degré on parle de
circonscriptions les secteurs où on est
régulièrement plus tendu et qui
montreraient que qu'il ya un
déséquilibre de notre force de
remplacement entre ces circonscriptions
et l'objectif c'est à la fois de
recapitaliser c'est-à-dire de
probablement dans le cadre de la
préparation de la rentrée prochaine
amener davantage de professeurs à
exercer cette fonction mais en même
temps de rééquilibrer notre potentiel de
remplacement encore une fois sur le
territoire yvelines l'éducation sujet
intarissable on a beaucoup de sujets sur
lequel vous fait réagir
l'actualité nationale aussi c'est najat
vallaud belkacem la ministre qui a
présenté le plan anti harcèlement à
l'école c'était le 6 février plusieurs
mesures formation des enseignants mise
en place d'un prix également mobilisons
nous contre le harcèlement harcèlement
pardon pour que les élèves puissent
directement s'exprimer
quelle est la situation sur sur le
harcèlement justement dans le
département
alors il faut bien convenir alors vous
imaginez bien qu'avec le recul qui est
le mien depuis un peu moins d'un mois je
peux pas en parler très savamment
simplement ce que je sais c'est que
aujourd'hui on voit une montée en
puissance j'allais dire du nombre de
signalements et ça montre bien que le
travail qui est impulsée au niveau
national et repris au niveau du
département porte ses fruits
trop longtemps les enfants les parents
et parfois peut-être même les
enseignants pour peu qu'ils sont au
courant de ce qui se passe on retenu une
information on a eu du mal aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit que la tendance s'inverse
qu' on est beaucoup plus fréquemment
informé de ces situations et on a
développé dans le même temps notre
capacité à les prendre en charge
et c'est cela qui importe puisque on
sait très bien que ce sont des
traumatismes et des traumatismes durable
et qui malheureusement n'ont pas été
pris suffisamment attendant la scolarité
des enfants puisque on s'aperçoit que le
premier degré par exemple est concerné
et peut être concernée de façon assez
assez grave est assez lourde
aujourd'hui le site d'abord le
dispositif est rendue visible
cette question est bien prise en charge
dans nos écoles dans nos collèges et
dans nos lycées et nous avons une
capacité encore une fois à répondre que
ce soit avec des spécialistes de cette
question la voir avec d'autres
professionnels le cas échéant d'ailleurs
de la justice du du social de façon à
bien sécuriser les parcours des jeunes
qui sont victimes mais aussi à prendre
en charge les auteurs qui parfois ont
même des problématiques personnelles
tout aussi lourde donc la mise en place
du plan qui a été lancé par la ministre
ça va s'échelonner sur cette année sur
la prochaine rentrée scolaire ça va
s'échelonner on ne part pas de rien
puisqu'il y avait déjà des systèmes d'
alerte d un numéro vert qui est utilisé
et puis encore une fois des compétences
qui sont mobilisés au sein des
inspections académiques c'est le cas à
guyancourt avec une assistante sociale
et une équipe qui sont en capacité de
répondre d'abord à la demande que
peuvent formuler les chefs
d'établissement et des directeurs
d'école à des situations complexes pour
les dénouer mais surtout à prendre en
charge rapidement et durablement les
victimes de ces situations on va juste
faire une pause pour partir dans les
rues de saint quentin en yvelines notre
question du jour micro trottoir est-ce
que vous avez tout simplement déjà été
confronté à cette situation de
harcèlement à l'école
donc pendant plus enfin l'école n'ont
pas eu de problème particulier
donc ça existe oui mais bon heureusement
on n'a pas été touchée par ce phénomène
dans mon enfance je crois comme nous
tous on a déjà subi ces ports et
brimades cokerie qui ressemble plus ou
moins l'harcèlement et c'est un passage
un petit pas obligatoire tant que ça
reste du léger c'est peut-être pris plus
d'ampleur depuis le les téléphones
portables avec les vidéos qu'on peut
faire et le harcèlement qui se fait via
les sites les réseaux sociaux c'est donc
se chercher
oui oui oui moi et mes proches mais
essaie des trucs de céder truc de gosse
coiffant est ce que t'as pas le bon
vêtement ou parce que t'as pas le
dernier truc à la mode ou des choses
comme ça évidemment quand on est victime
de harcèlement c'est quelque chose qu'on
ressent mal après je pense qu'il faut en
parler avant tout que ses responsables
pédagogiques à ses proches et ses
parents etc
en parler et puis je pense que c'est en
parlons justement que les choses là
peuvent mieux se dénouer quoi on a fait
un numéro vert va s'afficher ainsi vous
êtes victime ou si vous connaissez des
gens qui sont proches victimes de
harcèlement à l'école n'hésitez pas à
contacter ce numéro vert que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure on continue
comme ça à égrainer un petit peu
l'actualité dans l'éducation avec le
nouveau directeur de département des
yvelines directeur académique on peut
aussi revenir avec vous sur les
événements tragiques qui ont touché la
france les attentats les violences qui
ont touché le pays et puis on a beaucoup
aussi beaucoup parler du coût des
problématiques à l'école il y avait des
difficultés par exemple à faire
respecter les minute de silence dans
certains établissements les enseignants
qui étaient un peu désemparé quelle
réponse vous leur avez apporté à ce
moment là alors d'abord sur les
phénomènes que vous évoquez un
de non respect de la minute de silence
il n'y aurait eu qu'un seul cas si tu
étais un cas de trop dans le même temps
il faut bien admettre que c'est un
phénomène qui a été extrêmement limités
dans dans le département et qui a été
prise en charge avec beaucoup
d'intelligence de par nos chefs
d'établissement et par nos enseignants
et les directeurs d'école de la même
façon je veux dire que ça a été un choc
extrêmement violent pour tout le monde
évidemment à la fois dans la dimension
citoyenne mais aussi professionnel quand
il s'est agit justement de revisiter
j'allais dire le travail réalisé par
l'école moi je veux redire ici tout le
soutien et qui est le mien aux équipes
pédagogiques et au à l'encadrement
éducatif de nos écoles et de nos
établissements scolaires le travail qui
est fait sur le respect des valeurs de
la république sur le vivre ensemble est
fait est engagé et réaliser au quotidien
bien entendu que ça n'est pas
satisfaisant bien entendu que des
événements de ce type nous interroger
nous oblige à être meilleur encore et
c'est cette mobilisation qui aujourd'hui
portés au niveau national par madame la
ministre est que nous reprenons bien
entendu au niveau des tories la cannelle
moyens supplémentaires qui ont été
données déjà dans un déficit moyen soir
un haltère vont prendre la forme déjà ne
j'allais dire d'une affirmation plus
importante sur ce fameux respect des
valeurs de la république comment les
porter comment aider comment équipés
intellectuellement les enseignants face
à des défis qui bougent aujourd'hui
comment mieux prendre en compte les
risques par exemple du numérique et ça
cette question de la formation appelle
un plan de développement qui sera porté
par mille formateur que nous allons
former au niveau national nous
retrouverons bien évidemment des
déclinaisons départementales
nous allons promouvoir l'enseignement
moral et civique avec une révision des
programmes qui est actuellement concours
qui sera le fil directeur finalement de
du travail que nous aurons à réaliser au
niveau de chacune des classes mais ce
que j'ai voulu au niveau du département
avec le procureur et le préfet c'est
avoir une réflexion avec l'ensemble de
l'encadrement
pour voir comment mieux répondre
justement à ces situations pour
lesquelles il faut l'admettre
certaines de nos équipes ont été démunis
il faut qu'on soit en capacité de mieux
les accompagner et de mieux les aider
nous allons décliner très très
prochainement une formation au bénéfice
des proviseurs des principaux des
inspecteurs et probablement des
directeurs d'école mais qui sera une
formation interministériel de façon à ce
que chacun puisse apporter une meilleure
connaissance des problématiques de
radicalisation par exemple qui sont
aussi extrêmement préoccupante dans bien
que limitée mais extrêmement
préoccupante et pour lesquels il faut
encore une fois avoir des d une capacité
à bien prendre en compte ces situations
mais surtout à bien les percevoir et à
bien les déceler sur la question du
vivre ensemble nous aurons à approfondir
a accentué le travail que nous faisons
aujourd'hui
et surtout vous le dites vous même à
mieux consolider l'aide que nous
apportons aux enseignants de manière à
ce qu'ils ne soient sentent pas encore
une fois dans le défi et et dans une
tension qui est déjà importante dans
certains secteurs
ça vous laisse une marge de manoeuvre
même au delà des événements tragiques
qui ont touché la france au delà des
problématiques nationales à votre poste
dans le département des yvelines vous
avez marge de manoeuvre bien dans ton
bull qui simule sait quels sont vos
projets vos priorités par exemple sur
ces questions là on peut alors bien
entendu il ya des débats autour des
territoires par exemple mais la question
des déséquilibres territoriaux se pose
parfaitement nous avons identifié avec
le conseil général un certain nombre de
secteurs où la question de la mixité
sociale se pose avec peut-être une
réflexion un travail sur la
sectorisation la répartition entre les
écoles et les collèges
nora a retravaillé et probablement
amplifier ce travail là en termes
éducatifs et en termes de prévention on
sait très bien que le numérique même si
c'est un des axes forts par exemple de 2
et qui fait consensus sur le département
et bien nous aurons à développer bien
entendu les équipements à développer les
usages dans le dans dans les pratiques
enseignantes et en même temps à bien
prévenir aussi certains usages qui
expose les no nos jeunes et nos enfants
et qui ont parfois des effets désastreux
dont on entend on peut imaginer les
conséquences
il y aura encore beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels vous faire réagir et nous reste
finalement assez peu de temps donc vous
aurez l'occasion de revenir sur ce
plateau bien évidemment juste une toute
dernière question vous étiez dans l'aube
auparavant alors je fais je connais déjà
l'académie de versailles pour un maïs
exercé comme adjoint dans les
hauts-de-seine
j'ai été effectivement inspecteur
d'académie de loeb et découvrir mes
mates et j'arrive de la loire et la
loire sont des problématiques j'ai une
carrière pratiquement francilienne
puisque j'ai exercé également dans
l'académie de créteil et d'avoir exercé
à la fois dans la loire et dans l'homme
a permis de découvrir notamment le monde
rural je retrouve dans les yvelines un
ensemble très contrastées et qui me va
bien merci ça fait moins des acteurs
académiques des services de l'éducation
nationale dans les yvelines d'être venu
donc ce soir en plateau merci et pour
finir ce journal de la culture le centre
de musique baroque de versailles et ses
partenaires notamment à l'académie de
versailles ont mené dans le cadre de l
année rameau 2014 un programme de
sensibilisation à l'art lyrique à
destination des élèves de trappes autour
d'une oeuvre emblématique de jean
philippe rameau les indes galantes le
reportage avant à quelques heures de la
représentation de ce soir à lammer et
attrape le reportage de catherine du
gâteau il me dira que des lumignons
la vie l'autre bras g t il des sites et
il chante du rameau dernières
répétitions à la merise avant le grand
saut ce sera ce mardi soir eux sont
élèves des collèges courbin gagarine le
village de trappes
en tout une soixantaine ils ont été
associés aux pages de la maîtrise du
centre musique baroque de versailles
accompagné d'instrumentistes étudiantes
des conservatoires de versailles de la
vallée de chevreuse il travaille depuis
le mois de septembre pour mettre au
point l'acte iv des indes galantes
l'oeuvre emblématique de jean philippe
rameau un projet pédagogique ambitieux
l'avenir ces deux groupes de jeunes qui
ne sont pas amenés à se rencontrer dans
la vie de tous les jours ils vont pas au
collège un même endroit ils ont pas
c'est pas le même public
on a d'un côté des enfants qui
son habituel et musique baroque de
l'autre pas du tout et qui pourrait tout
de suite voir une espèce de sentiment de
répulsion peut-être j'espère faire
naître un nouveau public les jeunes
trappistes et le centre de musique
baroque se sont retrouvés tous les
vendredis ici à la merise pour répéter
ils ont appris à chanter danser à
déclamer alors à quelques heures de
monter sur scène une certaine fierté
on connaît de nouvelles personnes la
pointe des choses c'est toujours utile
mais bon je pensais pas faire ça parce
que j'étais pas censé être dans cette
place avant c'est arrivé on m'a dit
qu'elle un projet jeter patrice tu
n'étais pas heureux mais toujours ça
c'est il ya des gens qui ont pas la
chance de faire ça au début ça a été un
petit peu difficile à faire passer le
projet parce que c'est dans une langue
c'est de l'ancien français donc ils
connaissent pas forcément les termes les
mots sont aussi un petit peu compliqué
et finalement se sont vite très vite
accroché parce que ce sont des mélodies
qu'il garde très vite en tête et du cou
dans la cour de récré certains le chante
comme il gérait chanter du beyoncé ou
autre chose sacrée quand même une sorte
de cohésion parce qu'on passe beaucoup
de temps ensemble finalement tous les
vendredis après midi on était ensemble à
travailler un mois j'ai beaucoup discuté
avec les élèves de tas de choses qui
sont pas en lien avec le projet mais ça
m'a permis de les connaître mieux et
comme je suis professeur principal ça me
ça m'aide quand même pour les connaître
et pour savoir comment ils réagissent
ils me parlent plus facilement de leurs
difficultés scolaires on va dire de
restitution publique vont avoir lieu
l'une dès ce mardi soir à la merise et
l'autre jeudi dans le prestigieux opéra
royal de versailles
c'est un travail en groupe
des musiciens et des chanteurs pour nous
va c'est de la chance en fait les
sauvages ont des chansons cherchant
dit-on est monotone mais ce qu ils ont
jugé qu'elle avait t'il une oreille
propre et fait aller bien entendre fin
du journal rendez vous demain aux mêmes
horaires sur notre antenne et puis à dès
à présent sur le site internet pour voir
le replay de cette édition des
précédentes et de l'intégralité de nos
reportages